let's imagine that we know what we want
to leave a relationship but that we're
suffering from a problem which inhibits
us from acting on our wishes we can't
bear to cause another person pain
especially another person towards whom
we feel a sense of loyalty who's been
kind to us who looks up to us for their
safety in their future who has
expectations of us and with whom we
might have been planning a trip together
to another continent in a few months
perhaps we've come near to telling them
on a dozen occasions but always pulled
back at the very last moment we tell
ourselves though we'll get around to it
after the holidays or once their
birthday party's over or next year or in
the morning and yet the deadlines rolled
by and we are still here our discomfort
has to do with the thought of unleashing
an appalling upset they will dissolve
into tears there will be sobbing which
may last a very long time there will be
wailing uncontrollable cries and
mountains of wet tissues all because of
a truth that currently lurks in the
quiet recesses of our cranium we will
have been responsible for dragging a
formerly competent and independent
person into chaos it's more than we can
bear it sounds peculiar but it might
almost be better for us to spend the
next few decades unfulfilled than
experience even five minutes of
unbounded upset in another part of our
minds there may also be a terror more
than we realize day to day we're scared
of our partner by telling them it's over
we risk a discharge of Titanic anger
they may scream at us accuse us of
leading them on of being a charlatan and
a disgrace there might be violence and
danger there is a certain symmetry to
our fears we may tell them and by doing
so kill them or we may tell them and
they will turn around and kill us kill
or be killed no wonder we put off the
news the reasonable adult part of our
minds knows that these fears are killing
and dying can't really be true but this
may weigh very little in how we
unconsciously feel
wielding sensible arguments can at
points be as effective as telling a
person with vertigo
that the balcony won't collapse or a
person with depression that there are
perfectly good grounds to be cheerful a
lot of our mind is not amenable to
hard-headed logic in an ancestral part
of us we simply operate with a sense
that going against the wishes of a
significant person will mean either
endangering their lives or our own to
explain the origins of such terrors
childhood is the place to turn as it
always is when trying to account for
disproportionate and limitless fears
perhaps we are the offspring of a
fragile parent whom we loved profoundly
and whom it would have broken our hearts
to disappoint they might have been
struggling with a mental or physical
health they might have been maltreated
by another adult maybe they were relying
on us to hold them back from despair or
justify their whole lives we may have
derived an early impression that we had
to conform to their idea of us if we
weren't to cause them grave damage that
our wishes and needs could easily have
driven them to the edge that by being
more ourselves we might have broken
their spirit we simply loved them too
much at the same time felt them to be
too weak to ask them to take on our
reality we can be three years old and
without knowing any of this consciously
have taken such messages on board and as
a result we might then have learnt to
play very quietly to rein in our
boisterousness or mischievousness our
aggression or our intelligence to be
extremely cheerful and helpful around
the house to be no trouble at all
towards a beloved adult who already
seemed to have far too much on their
plate alternatively we might have spent
almost vulnerable years around a person
who responded to any frustration caused
by another person with extreme anger it
can be hard to appreciate just how
terrifying an enraged adult can seem to
a sensitive two-year-old another adult
might know that this red-faced figure of
course wasn't gonna murder anyone
they're just letting rip for a while and
we'll pick up the pieces of a smashed
farce soon enough
but that's not at all how it can seem
through a child's eyes how would they to
know that this person many times their
size wouldn't just go one step further
and at the end of their ranting pick up
a hammer and smash their skull in
how can they be certain that the
momentarily genuinely out-of-control
parent who just broke the door wouldn't
for that matter throw them out of the
window to child murder may be entirely
alien to the furious adult but that's
not how it can strike a sensitive
offspring one doesn't have to actually
murder anyone to come across to an
unformed mind as someone who seriously
might no wonder we might be a bit scared
of sharing some awkward news
our minds are freita dwith fears that
stem from things that happened under
precise circumstances long ago but that
continued to have a potent subterranean
scarcely recognized an immense force in
our lives today by taking stock of the
past the task is to acknowledge that
these fears are very real but only in a
very limited space our own minds they
don't belong to adult reality the
catastrophe we fear will happen has
already happened we have already
experienced someone who seemed to risk
killing themselves if the news grew too
bad and someone who looked like they
were perhaps going to kill whomever
displeased them but these issues are
firmly located in another era we need to
take on board an always unlikely
sounding thought we are now adults which
means there is robustness to ourselves
and to our dealings with others another
adult is highly unlikely to collapse on
us and if they do there are plenty of
measures we can take we will know how to
help them cope with their grief directly
and indirectly it may seem as if it will
never end
but that is a child's reasoning not an
adults in reality it will be very bad
for a few hours or days or weeks but
then eventually as happens they will get
over it they will recover their good
humor they will wake up one morning and
see the world hasn't ended and that they
know how to go on similarly they won't
actually try to pick up the nearest axe
and chop us into small pieces they may
be furious they may shout there may be
some ugly words but again we are now
tall
an independent we can get away in
extremists we have the number of the
police and a lawyer we can let the fury
vent and like a well-built bridge in a
hurricane be utterly confident that we
can withstand anything that will come
our way to further lend us courage we
should remember a distinction between
being kind and seeming kind it can look
as if the kind thing to do is never to
anger or distress anyone and therefore
never to give a person we have loved
unwelcome news but that is to overlook
the more insidious ways in which we can
ruin someone's life to stay with a
person because we wish to avoid a few
hours of unpleasantness is no favor to
them if we then go on to be bitter mean
snide unfaithful and depressed around
them for the next few decades we're not
helping someone by sparing them a bad
breakup scene if we then deliver a
lifelong foot-dragging scene a
surprising amount of the misery of the
world comes from people being overly
keen to appear kind or rather who are
too cowardly to cause others short-term
pain the truly courageous way to leave
is to allow ourselves to be hated for a
while by someone who still loves us we
shouldn't imagine that they will never
find anyone else like us they may
believe it now and might even sweetly
tell us so but they won't believe it
when they finally understand who we are
real kindness means getting out even
though the holidays been booked the
apartment paid for and the wedding
arranged there's nothing wrong with and
nothing dangerous about deciding that
someone isn't for us there is something
very wrong with ruining large chunks of
someone else's life while we squeamish
me or fearfully hesitate to get out of
the way
deciding whether to stay in or leave a
relationship is one of the trickiest and
most consequential decisions we can face
our stay or leave card game can help us
towards an answer click now to learn
more